(jubilant music)
(cars rev loudly)
- [Hamda] Between me and my sister,
there's a lot of competition.
- It's a race, everybody wants to win,
but off-track, we're just like
any other normal teenager.
We hang out with our
family, with our friends.
But, in racing, it's
where we feel most alive.
(robust energetic music)
- My name is Amna Al
Qubaisi, I'm 17 years old.
- And my name is Hamda Al
Qubaisi and I'm 15 years old.
- [Amna] And we are the
first Emirati female drivers.
- What I love most about racing is,
you can always do better and better.
It's the best feeling
when you feel the speed
and you can improve so
fast, just by focusing.
(pulsing inspirational music)
- I first became interested
in go-karting when I saw
my dad racing inside
and outside of the UAE.
All he ever talked about
was racing and meeting
different drivers around the world,
and going to different tracks.
He's always there to help me calm down,
and he plays a really big
role in my recent career.
(pulsing inspirational music)
- I have been racing
professionally since 2009.
I first noticed the talent
in my daughter, Amna,
when she was three years old.
She saw a quad and she wanted to drive it,
and before even giving
her any instructions,
she knew where the throttle is,
where the brakes are.
So, I immediately know
that she had the touch.
Hamda, her sister, she wanted
to also to get into racing.
And she surprised us all
because in her first season,
she was able to win races.
(pulsing inspirational music)
- So far, I have 16
trophies and three wins.
- I've won over 20 trophies,
including four wins,
and still counting.
My mom, she helps me, she
takes me to the tracks,
she takes me around the world.
- Yeah, she's the best. (laughs)
- Both of them are always
competing, which make it
very interesting for us, as a family.
It's very interesting to see
them racing against boys.
It show how girls can race against a boy,
and can win a race.
(cars rev loudly)
- Being the first Emirati to win the
UAE RMC championship is pretty big.
There's no female Emirati
that's done it before.
It was a big achievement.
(cars rev loudly)
- I believe my daughters
are breaking barriers
for women, in general.
And our women, in particular.
We're happy to see that
people's perception
are being changing about
our region and culture,
and about women, in general.
And I believe that this
is great for motor sports.